YURI: Good morning
and good afternoon,
everyone out there
on the internet.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
We really appreciate it.
My name is Yuri.
I'm a customer engineer
here at Google,
and I'm joined by my
partner in beardedness
and laptop sticker
collection, Nick.
NICK: Hey, Yuri.
How's it going?
YURI: Good, man.
NICK: Yeah, I'm definitely
happy to be here.
I know that we have an
exciting topic to cover today.
As you mentioned, my
name is Nick [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm also a customer engineer.
And we are fortunate enough to
have one of our amazing rock
stars, Karthi, on.
Karthi, you want to
introduce yourself?
KARTHI: Hey, Nick and Yuri.
So yeah, my name's
Karthi Thyagarajan.
I won't expect you
to say my last name.
I'm a solutions architect
based out of Dallas.
And I've got serious
sticker envy,
because all I have is
this Google Cloud sticker.
[LAUGHTER]
YURI: Well, listen, man,
you've got a long time
before you can catch up to us.
I tend to be a
sticker maximalist,
so I'm pretty much
just collecting
whatever I get my hands on.
Not a whole lot of
discretion being applied.
So first, thank you so much
for being here with us.
You introduce yourself
as a solution architect.
Can you give us a
30-second summary
of what does a solution
architect do at Google?
KARTHI: Yeah, great question.
In a lot of ways, we are very
similar to a customer engineer.
One of the key
differences, of course,
is that we don't focus
on specific customers.
We work with various
areas of specialty.
In my case, it's big data.
So I focus on streaming
data, along with--
actually, streaming and batch,
and then quite a bit of app
dev as well.
So for example, if
a customer wants
to figure out how they
can leverage Dataflow
to do both stream processing
as well as batch processing,
and they have a lot of
experience, let's say,
doing Hive on-prem, I would
basically work with them
to translate some
of the existing
implementations to doing it in
a more cloud-native fashion.
So that's an example of what a
solutions architect would do.
NICK: Awesome.
I mean, when it comes to
what's valuable to a company,
number one is definitely their
data and their employees.
So being able to extract
some useful information
and new insights from that
data is incredibly powerful.
So I'm sure you must
be a very busy guy.
KARTHI: You can say that again.
NICK: Yeah.
YURI: And once again, we
appreciate you being with us.
So as you can imagine, a
lot of the questions that we
get are around, how do customers
make use of their data?
Some of the questions that
I've been hearing more recently
are not just about, how do
people make use of the data--
basically, at the end
of their data pipeline
or at the end of
their processing,
or how they can actually
answer some questions
about what's going
on with their data
before it even gets to
its final destination.
We talk a lot about ML.
Obviously, we're an
AI-first company.
But people want to
know, how do they
get sense of the stuff that's
going on in their environment
before they have a chance
to train and deploy
a machine learning model?
So I'm really happy
that you're here today.
Because what I want
to hear from you
is what you're
seeing customers do,
especially where different
roles in the organization
are concerned, to actually
utilize their data at all
of the different stages of
the pipeline or the lifecycle.
Does that makes sense?
KARTHI: Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
I think that is
something that I've
heard on multiple occasions as
well, so happy to get into it.
YURI: All right, let's do that.
NICK: Cool.
KARTHI: Great!
And as based on
past meetups, I want
to emphasize before
I get into the slides
that the slide portion
will be pretty light.
And I think that's a good thing.
We'll get into demos after
about four or five slides.
So to start out with
I'll reemphasize the fact
that this discussion
came out of Nick, myself,
and Yuri talking about the
data lifecycle solution
that we put out.
But you can Google
data lifecycle on GCP.
You'll find it.
It should be the first
link that shows up.
The key here is there are many
stages that make up the data
lifecycle, starting with
collect, ingest, all the way
to visualize.
But the focus of
this discussion--
we will talk about the personas.
And even within
the personas, we'll
focus on what a
data scientist does.
And as Yuri pointed
out earlier, we'll
look at how we can surface
insights from, let's say,
the vast amounts of data that
any typical enterprise gathers.
But I also want to point out
that data doesn't necessarily
mean that it should be limited
to data scientists or analysts.
You will also have software
developers, system architects,
et cetera, who will have say
so, as well as decision making
ability when it comes
to how data progresses
through the lifecycle.
YURI: Yeah, absolutely.
Makes a lot of sense so far.
KARTHI: Yeah, so,
well, as I mentioned,
while we won't touch on
the software developer
side of things, I
just want to mention
this is a familiar flow that
most folks have been seeing
for, I would say,
at least 50 years
now-- ever since the
advent of computers.
There's some kind of
data collection going on.
They'll store it in a relational
database of some sort,
and then they'll visualize it.
So this is the
simplest kind of flow
that most people
are familiar with.
To take it a little further,
now what we're getting into
is the fact that data has
become so much more valuable
than this previous
slide would indicate.
Data becomes the engine
for entire businesses,
and what we're
hoping to do today
is give you some insight
into why that is.
And so in this space,
you'll see the persona
of the data scientist
and analyst playing
a much more significant role.
YURI: So looking
at this right now--
because the flow of
the software developer
basically ends with
the store step.
And that's where someone like a
data scientist or data analyst
would actually pick it up.
So the key point here is
that depending on who you are
there are different things
you need to do with the data.
There's different
kinds of analysis
you might want to do because
even a software developer may
need to use the data that's
flung to their system
to understand things
like system performance,
issues that may be
taking place, or things
that could be potentially
negatively impacting user
experience.
And I know that software
developer role and persona's
not necessarily the focus
of what you'll be covering.
We'll be talking more
about the other personas
in this particular
session, but I certainly
want folks to
think about, how do
they expose data in
their environment
to everyone that
might benefit from it?
KARTHI: Yeah, that's right.
And yeah, another
takeaway, I would say,
is it is super important
for these personas
to work together.
And the roles are often
blurred, as you would agree,
because I've often seen
data scientists who
will wear the software
developer hat when it comes time
to take all the experimentation
they've done with the store
and say, OK, now I got
to productize this.
I've got to put this
out in production
and, let's say, expose
a machine learning
endpoint that can be called
by all these other services.
So at that point, you have a
blurring of personas as well.
YURI: Yeah, awesome.
Yeah, all right, let's carry on.
KARTHI: Cool, so as I mentioned,
before we get into the demo,
let's just look at
this very simple flow.
Essentially, what
we're going to do
is we're going to
create a toy example.
And it starts with this
simple driver program
that we created that dumps
a whole bunch of orders
into Pub/Sub.
These are orders that have some
basic information, as we'll
see, like the name of the
person that made the order,
as well as a widget ID
that indicates that they
ordered this particular widget.
So it'll go through Pub/Sub.
It'll be processed by Dataflow.
And then from Dataflow,
we'll put it into BigQuery.
And so that's the store phase.
And once it lands in BigQuery,
this is where a business--
let's say an e-tailer
or a retailer--
can start to make sense
of the kinds of purchasing
decisions that are
being made by customers.
And one of, obviously,
the key insights
there is, how are customers
deciding what to buy, right?
This is a question
that often gets asked.
So we'll look at
some ways of creating
models that help us predict some
of those purchasing decisions.
And we'll use something called
Datalab, which is essentially
a hosted Jupyter Notebook,
and this is usually
the realm of data scientists.
And from Datalab, what we'll do
is once we've honed the model,
we'll deploy that model to
a fully-managed serverless
machine learning system called
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
Does that sound good, guys?
NICK: Sounds great, yeah.
Definitely looking
forward to it.
Let's dig into the data.
YURI: One thing I
want to emphasize
here is that we've
actually covered
a lot of these components and
products on other sessions.
We had a session on streaming.
So if folks want to learn
more about how Pub/Sub works,
how you can go about
writing Dataflow transforms,
how BigQuery works--
we certainly got a lot
of collateral on that
and done sessions on this
very meetup to cover those.
So I don't want to necessarily
spend too much time
on the infrastructure
piece of this
or how you actually
get the data flowing.
I think the key thing we
want to keep emphasizing--
the key thing that I'm
going to be coming back
to as we talk for
the next 20 minutes
or so-- is, how do we
use the data at each step
rather than how do we
get the data to flow?
NICK: Yeah, how do we
tie it all together?
KARTHI: No, that's
a great point, yeah.
Yeah, with that in mind, I
won't spend any time on--
actually, I'll spend
very little time
on the ingest piece
and the processing
piece with the understanding
that folks already
have seen this presented
on this very meetup.
So what I'll do is--
let me just quickly touch on
the nature of the data that's
flowing through the system.
So this is some Python code,
and I've kept it simple.
So all I'm going to show here
is that we have an order ID,
an order created date, the
name of the customer, something
that takes the place of
the customer phone number,
and then the widget
ID, as I've mentioned.
So these are the
fields that you have
to keep in mind as the data
flows through this system
as we inspect it at each
of these lifecycle stages.
And let me also quickly
show the Dataflow processes.
And the key takeaway
here is how simple
it is to write a Dataflow job.
All we're doing here is we're
subscribing to a Pub/Sub topic,
and essentially, as
the messages come in,
we are putting
them into BigQuery.
You have quite a
bit of flexibility
as far as what you could
do with filtering and maybe
enriching the data as it's
flowing through the system.
We're not doing that.
So with that said,
let's quickly look
at what's in BigQuery so
that we can then look at what
we can do with that data.
So as Yuri mentioned,
I'm sure you're
familiar with the BigQuery UI.
This Meetup Demo DS is the
data set that I've created,
and within that data set, I have
a table called BigQuery Demo
Table.
Essentially, that table
mirrors the payload
that I showed you earlier.
OK, and I've got quite
a few records here.
So now let's look at what
a data scientist would
want to do with this data.
And this is where--
a data scientist is
perfectly comfortable
dealing with a data
warehouse like BigQuery.
However, they also
want the power
of something like
Jupyter Notebook.
A lot of data scientists work
in R, in Python, et cetera.
And in this case, we'll focus
on Python with Jupyter Notebook.
So Jupyter Notebook has
its ancestry in IPython.
They renamed it.
And now you have all of
that power available to you
as a hosted service.
And the name of that
service is Cloud Datalab.
And the way you interact with
Datalab is actually with a CLI.
There isn't a UI within the GCP
console that you can get to.
So essentially what
you would have to do
is install the Datalab CLI.
And once you get to the
CLI, you have the ability
to create a Datalab instance,
and then you can connect to it.
So as I mentioned, you
have Create, Connect, List,
et cetera.
So let's look at Datalab List to
see how many Datalab instances
I have running.
As you can see here, I
have one instance running,
and it's in US central.
And by the way, you can also
specify the machine type
that you would like.
For certain kinds
of number crunching,
you may want a bigger instance.
In this case, I've gone
with a standard-4, which
is a little bit bigger than
what you'd get by default.
So let me pause
there real quick.
Nick and Yuri, do you
guys have anything
that you want me to
focus on before I get
to the actual Notebook itself?
NICK: Actually, I
have one question.
So you're talking about,
from the overall pipeline
perspective, the data's going
to be streaming through Pub/Sub
and then going through Dataflow.
And then at the
end, it's basically
pipelined into the data
warehouse named BigQuery.
So it supports streaming
directly into the--
basically into your BigQuery
table using a streaming API.
Do you mind talking
about the pros and cons
of going your route of streaming
through Pub/Sub and then
Dataflow versus
directly to BigQuery?
KARTHI: Yeah, that's
a great point.
So one reason that
comes to mind as
to why you should
go with Pub/Sub
is if you want more
flexibility, let's say,
in filtering or
transforming the data--
if you have requirements that
require heavy transformations
against the data before it
lands in a store like BigQuery,
I would definitely
recommend that you
go with putting
Dataflow in the middle.
For simple ingest
scenarios, I think
it's perfectly OK to
leave out Dataflow.
But usually in an enterprise
scenario that's not the case.
NICK: Yeah, that makes
sense, especially when
you're scaling up.
OK.
How about you, Yuri?
Any questions that you have
before we get kicked off?
YURI: No, sir.
I want to see how this
all is going to work.
NICK: There we go.
Cool.
KARTHI: Awesome.
OK, so let's get to
the Notebook itself.
So real quick, I already have a
Notebook running and connected.
So when you run Datalab
connect and give it
the name of the actual
Datalab instance, what it does
is it creates an SSH tunnel, and
then it automatically pops up
a browser window--
like I've done here.
And you can see here that the
address is localhost 8081.
And you can change this port to
another port if you so choose,
but this makes it really easy
to connect to this essentially
separate VM with all
the goodies installed.
So we're talking NumPy.
We're talking
TensorFlow-- everything
that a data
scientist would want.
And to continue with a quick
tour of what this Notebook
gives you, if you were to start
this up, what you can do is--
let me just-- sorry.
Let me just scroll
up here and show you
that what you have
here with Datalab
is essentially a managed service
that anybody who has access
to that project can connect to.
So every time somebody
opens a Notebook,
what they get is a separate
kernel that runs the Notebook
that they're looking at.
And once you're
done, essentially,
if you're seeing
that the resource
usage for that
instance is heavy,
you can shut down
that Notebook so
that you're freeing up
memory, CPU usage, et cetera.
YURI: So Karthi, let
me ask you a question.
I imagine that some
folks on the line
may or may not be familiar.
They probably-- I'm sure they've
heard of Python, but Jupyter--
it's a bit of a different
paradigm, right?
Lots of people are familiar
writing Python code in an IDE.
Tell us a little bit about
why do people use Jupyter.
What has it given that
command line Python doesn't?
KARTHI: Another great question.
So one of the big things
is you essentially get
this ability to mix
markdown and actual code.
So that even if
you, yourself, were
the only one working
in this Notebook,
you have self-documenting code.
So if I were to open
up this guy here--
Introduction to Notebooks.
And by the way, this is
all built into Datalab.
You can open up these
examples and play with it.
So you can see, this
looks like a web page.
Very well-documented.
You find a cell and you
put in your Python code.
And you hit Control-Enter,
or you can just click on Run,
and it actually runs the code.
And all of it is documented.
You can save it.
You can share these
notebooks with other people.
So it's the collaboration and
the self-documenting aspect
of it, I would say, is one
of the most powerful things
about doing it this way
versus running it in an IDE
like Python.
YURI: Awesome, thank you.
KARTHI: Does that help?
YURI: Yeah, very much so.
All right, so now, how do we use
data in Pub/Sub or in BigQuery
within Jupyter?
KARTHI: Yeah, that's
definitely one
of the significant
capabilities with Datalab
is the integration is built in.
So for example,
there are these--
Jupyter Notebook, by the
way, gives you the ability
to run these magic commands.
That's what they're called.
And what the Datalab
folks have done
is they've enhanced
that to add the ability
to integrate with GCP
services like BigQuery.
So this is a magic command here.
It's %%bq query.
And then what I can
do is submit a query,
like I would into
the BigQuery UI,
and then I get the
results right here.
And that integration
is really powerful.
Because what you can then
do on top of this is now
you can bring in
the power of all
of the other number crunching,
visualization capabilities.
So as an example,
what I've done here
is I've created this variable.
Sorry, it's called
DF in this case.
DF to signify that
it's a data frame.
So the data scientist
amongst the audience
will recognize data frames.
And data frames, obviously,
come with really powerful data
science capabilities, for
lack of a better phrase.
So you can populate
this data frame.
And then you can go
on, as I've done here,
to do some more visualization.
So what I've done is I've
taken this data frame,
and essentially what
I'm trying to do
here is model the relationship
between the person who put it
in order and the
type of widget it
is just to see if I
can actually use it
for predictive analytics.
So this both goes to illustrate
the power of combining all
the GCP services-- as
you've mentioned, Yuri--
along with what Datalab adds
in terms of capabilities.
So in this case, I take the
data out of the BigQuery query
that I did, and then
I'm plotting it.
So you can see that there's
a linear relationship
between the name of
the person that put
in an order and the widget ID.
And obviously, this is
a contrived example,
but this gives
you an idea of how
you can do some
visualization directly
against the data of BigQuery.
YURI: Very cool.
All right, so I
think that gives us
a great perspective on the data
scientist's experience in GCP,
using data from BigQuery
as it first arrives--
either directly from
Pub/Sub streaming
or from the Dataflow transform.
What other persona
do you have in mind
for taking advantage of
data from different steps
of the pipeline
over the lifecycle?
KARTHI: Yeah, so
if we were to go
beyond just this
ability to experiment,
you have the analyst who has to,
let's say, actually implement--
actually, before I
get to the analyst,
let's talk about the
system architect who
has to, maybe, implement
the predictive analytics
that a data scientist has
gleaned from this graph here.
So the data
scientist says, oh, I
have a light bulb moment here.
I know that this is how
customers are making decisions
on what to order.
So let us now actually
create a machine
learning model that will
take all this training data--
all this gold, basically-- and
suggest widgets for customers
to buy.
So to implement this at scale,
what a system architect would
have to do is essentially go
to this training data that's
in BigQuery and
say, OK, I'm going
to do some feature engineering.
And to do this at
scale, a product
that we recently released
is called Dataprep.
So if you're cool with it,
Yuri, shall we move to Dataprep
and talk about what
that can do for us?
YURI: Yeah, absolutely.
I'm really interested
in seeing how--
now that we understand the
life of a data scientist
on GCP, I think we want to
see, how does an architect
benefit from this data as well?
NICK: Yeah, the biggest
challenge that I've run into
frequently is just that the
data comes in all jumbled,
and there's really no
way of simply cleaning it
up and preparing it.
So we'll have to
see what you can do.
KARTHI: Awesome.
Cool.
So as we discussed, we have
this data that's in BigQuery.
So let's pull up Dataprep
and extract, essentially,
what are called features that'll
help us do some predictions.
And a picture is worth
a thousand words,
so let's actually create
something called a flow.
What a flow is--
you can think of
it as a transform.
It helps you take raw data
and shape it into something
that you can use for a
machine learning model.
Because oftentimes, you
can't just take raw data
and apply training to it,
because the data's probably not
going to be in a
shape that you want.
So let's do a very uncreative
name for this flow here.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to add a data
set that is going
to be the source data set
for this transformation
that we talked about.
And for that, I'm
going to pick a source.
So as you can see,
to start off with,
you can either
pull a GCS object,
or you can go to
BigQuery as the source,
and you can pick a table.
In this case, we're going
to pick this table, which
is where the order data landed.
Once we've picked the
source, what we can then do
is we can edit the way the
transformation functions.
And we can do it in a
visual, UI-based fashion,
and this is one of the key
capabilities of Dataprep.
You're not writing
a bunch of code--
which, there's nothing
wrong with writing code.
But a lot of times it's
hard for people to picture
what the data looks like.
And that's one of the really
powerful aspects of Dataprep.
So we have the source data.
So we create something
called a recipe.
And a recipe is something
that, essentially,
applies to the data.
And let's edit this
recipe to tell it what
to do with the raw data here.
As you can tell, it's loading
the demo table that I created.
And I'm sure you'll
recognize all these columns.
It's the same columns
that I showed you
in that Python class--
Order ID, Order Created
Date, et cetera.
And right off the bat,
what you'll notice
is Dataprep does a
good job of adding
visual indicators to the data.
So for example, it'll tell
me this name, Jennifer Smith,
occurs 0.04% in
the whole data set.
So these are really cool.
But what's even more
powerful is it'll tell me,
hey, there are different shapes
for customer phone number,
and also, there are 1,925 rows
that don't have customer phone.
So you can see
there's a lot of power
here in giving you the
ability to filter--
leave out things that
may not be helpful.
YURI: That's a really
important point, there,
is that you can
quickly understand,
what does the data look like?
Do I have outliers?
Are there gaps?
So let's say that the thing
you were trying to figure out
is the location
of your customers.
Phone number might be a really
important piece of information
there, because the area code
gives you very precise location
information if you don't have
GPS data or anything like that.
And if that's a key part
of what you're doing,
then having some significant
portion of your data
not have a phone number makes
it somewhat less useful.
KARTHI: That's right.
NICK: And just out
of curiosity, it
seems like this does a lot
of the transformational piece
that Dataflow also drives.
So what's the relationship
between Dataprep and Dataflow?
KARTHI: Great point.
Dataprep is actually
built on top of Dataflow.
And the reason that's
significant is that once you--
as we'll do here-- once
you create this transform,
it is actually run
within Dataflow,
which means we can deal
with hundreds of terabytes--
or even petabytes-- of
data because of the scalar
capabilities that Dataflow
brings to the table.
NICK: Awesome.
That's interesting.
KARTHI: Yeah, so let's
actually-- sorry, go ahead.
YURI: I'm sorry
to interrupt you.
In the interest of keeping
this to a manageable length--
because I think we could easily
be here for an hour or two
hours talking about everything--
I think this visibility
with Dataprep
gives folks really excellent
understanding of how
they can go about doing some
of that data wrangling and data
clean up.
And then, like
you said, creating
those transforms that would
then make this data more useful
or actually clean
it up automatically.
So let me ask you,
to shift gears
a little bit, let's talk
about that last persona
that we wanted to cover.
KARTHI: Yeah.
So essentially, this is the
persona that brings together
the machine learning--
sorry, the data scientist
with the machine
learning models, as
well as the analyst,
and then also the
system architect.
In this case, this
is the person that's
implementing the entire system
and then bringing it online
so it can do online predictions
and things of that nature.
So I'll segue to that persona
by talking about how Dataprep
can be leveraged to generate
the raw data to do the machine
learning.
So in this case, I've
picked out all the raw data
that doesn't have missing
order IDs for whatever reason.
And then I run
this Dataflow job.
And as Nick pointed out--
sorry, this Dataprep job.
As Nick pointed out,
just to show you,
when you run a Dataprep job, it
actually shows up in Dataflow,
as you can see here.
And this just confirms the fact
that underneath the covers,
Dataprep is actually
using Dataflow.
OK, so with that said,
let's now jump back
to our Jupyter Notebook and
look at our system architect
persona--
how they would take a
machine learning model
that the data scientist
has put together,
and how they will generate
a prediction engine
for predictive analytics.
YURI: All right, sounds great.
KARTHI: Awesome.
Cool.
So this is going to
be very light in terms
of actual machine
learning modeling.
I mean, this is a very
unsophisticated model, just
for demonstration purposes.
So keep that in mind.
Anyway, so the data
scientist has determined
that there's a very
simple linear relationship
between the name of the
person that's making the order
and the widget that
ends up getting ordered.
So what we're going
to do is we will
take the cleansed
data that Dataprep
puts into a GCS bucket.
It's in the CSV file.
Let me select it here.
And with that,
what we will do is
we will create a training data
set as well as a test data set.
And this is actually
how TensorFlow typically
works is you have to
have a training data set,
and then you train your
model with a certain number
of iterations, and then you test
that model with the test data
set to make sure that
things aren't out of whack.
Cool.
So the way you do that--
without going into too many
of the details--
is you basically--
as I mentioned,
you basically create
the training data set
and the test data set,
and then you leverage
something called an estimator.
This is built into
TensorFlow, and you
have a variety of estimators
that you can pick from.
In this case, we'll use the
simple linear regression model,
here, to train, and
we'll set up inputs
that come from the training
data set that we talked about.
And essentially, after
that, we say, hey,
let's run this training for
300 steps and one evaluation
that goes against the test
data set that I mentioned.
With all of that
put into this task
Python file, what we can then
do is try out the model locally.
And all I have to
do is run the model.
This is, by the way, not
running on ML Engine,
even though it is
referencing ML Engine.
What this is doing is
taking the training data
and running it in
my Datalab instance.
So that's important to remember.
Once that's satisfactory,
we're happy with the model
performance, things like
that, we can actually
run it in the cloud.
And the way the
flow would go is--
so the system
architect, let's say,
would try this out in the cloud.
And they would leverage
the power of the GCP Cloud.
They have the ability to pick
a whole bunch of scale tiers.
As some of you
may know, training
is often the most
time-consuming aspect
of doing predictive
analytics, because it requires
some serious horsepower.
And this is where being able
to tell Google Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, hey, I
want to use 10 machines,
or I want to use three GPUs--
you can specify all
of that here when
you're doing the
training in the cloud.
You may bring in terabytes
of data to do that training.
So then the training is done.
You also, then, have
the ability to look
at the characteristics of--
I apologize.
I have to rerun this again.
But basically, if you guys
are familiar with TensorBoard,
you have the ability to look
at where the model lands
and all the characteristics
of the training,
and you can inspect
it with TensorBoard.
So that'll tell you, hey,
this is the loss function.
This is how long
it took to run--
things of that nature.
Once you have run the model
and you're happy with it,
you can deploy it.
And what does deployment mean?
So deployment has to do with
actually having Cloud Machine
Learning Engine.
Once again, this is
fully serverless.
We're not talking about
individual computers
or your own managed cluster.
We're talking about a
managed service hosting
the model for you, and then
you can have it do predictions.
And the way that works is
you essentially tell it, hey,
this is where my model is
after training is complete.
In this case, it
landed in this--
when I say "it," machine
learning engine--
after the training is
complete, landed the model
in this GCS bucket
that you specified.
And basically, you
can take that model
and then use it
to do predictions.
And what we're going to do
here is basically pass it
inputs just to see, hey,
what kind of predictions
am I getting?
So this is something
we can actually
do because I've deployed the
model with Machine Learning
Engine.
And you can do it, actually,
directly from Datalab.
That's one of the cool
things about using Datalab,
is you don't have to exit
this environment that data
scientists are probably
comfortable in--
or also system
architects-- and leverage
the model that you've
deployed to production
to do some predictions.
Let me pause there real
quick while this is running
and see if there are any
additional questions that I
can address.
NICK: Yeah, anything
on the live stream?
YURI: We don't have any
questions in the live stream,
but I think this may be a
great place to wrap it up.
Thank you so much for
showing us how data can
flow through a pipeline in GCP.
Thanks for showing us
how to make sense of it
as it arrives in
BigQuery and some
of that first level
of analytics you
can do just with things
like SQL queries.
How do we do that next level of
analysis as a data scientist,
using the host of Jupyter
service with Cloud Datalab.
How to make sure the data's
good and clean and useful
with Dataprep, and
then how to take it
to the next level with either
local ML or a cloud ML Engine.
I thought this was fantastic,
really useful information.
Thank you, Karthi.
Really appreciate your time.
Like you said at the
start, you're a busy man,
and we really appreciate
you taking the time out
to talk to us.
NICK: Yeah, absolutely.
KARTHI: Thank you.
Really enjoyed it.
Thank you for your time.
YURI: All right, folks,
thank you so much.
As always, like, rate,
and subscribe-- right?
That's what you say
when you're on YouTube.
NICK: I guess so.
YURI: And Nick and I will be
back next week with another GCP
customer story.
So please tune in then.
It should be on the
schedule already,
or we'll get it on the
schedule as soon as possible.
Thanks, everyone.
Have a great day, and
we'll talk to you soon.
NICK: Yep, till next time.
Thanks, everyone.